hey hello everybody and welcome to
episode number 10 of my GE only
challenge uh today we're starting off
with another goal that we pretty much
hit last episode and that is a 750 total
level to go into the verac sewer uh the
sewer is going to offer mainly just
better combat experience but I'll have a
look around there and see if there's
anything else useful although I didn't
really see anything on the map but who
knows uh so 750 total level for the
sewer another goal for this episode is
going to get my construction up I want
to get it to 50 5 uh for the armor
repair stand cuz that's kind of the only
thing that's going to be useful until
the later levels of construction so I'm
going to get it to 55 uh sometime soon
and then probably leave it there for a
while because construction is really
expensive and another goal of course is
unlocking herblore but that's not I'm
not in a huge rush for that uh more
importantly I want to level up my
farming level and just generally get
more money now interestingly enough this
week a ton of items have been crashing
uh so have to see we can take advantage
of some flips or maybe the barrows
repair will work well once I get the
armor stand so anyway thanks for
watching guys and let's get started um
so I'm going to start off the episode by
leveling up my prayer a little bit um
this should be enough to get me to 30
for now and I don't want to go too
overboard on this because I'm burying
them in the ground which is pretty much
a waste uh if I had the guilded alter
I'll be getting triple The Experience uh
but at the same time this is going to be
some easy to hold levels and uh might
might consider getting it to 35 but for
now I'll just get it to 30 okay so we're
just about to hit 30 prayer pretty nice
and uh I did calculate the cost of
getting to 35 pray and that's going to
be about
500k uh in about an hour I don't really
think I'm going to do that now uh I can
get some other total levels easier in
other skills uh and it just again very
wasteful and I'd rather just bury these
bones when I actually have a gold alter
cuz if we go ahead and pop it up to what
I need it's like about 1,500 or some
bones that's going to be about 400 to
500k okay I have a couple flips coming
in the toy cats were the most profitable
by far I ended up buying them for 330k
each and I think I sold them for
600k uh which is really nice and we'll
pull all these offers out quickly and
yeah 600k so that's about 270k in on toy
cats uh The Old Demon masks about 180k
and the upgrade kits H just a little bit
only about 30k on those also I did end
up Buy a dragon axe which I'm kind of
looking forward to use all right I'm
just at the U trees right now I just hit
61 wood cutting recently so I can now
wield the dragon axe now with this axe
The Experience rate is about 25 to 30k
an hour probably closer to 25 uh at the
willow tree the singular tree it's about
30 to 40K an hour so it's definitely
slower here but I can AFK here a lot
longer which is just kind of nicer for
me plus you do get a little bit of money
I think maybe once I can grow the maple
tree I may switch back over but for now
this is pretty nice and there we go
perfect there is 62 wood cutting okay I
think we're just about to hit another
farming level cuz our will tree actually
grew and there we go there is Level 33
farming canot grow banana trees but uh I
can't actually do that we still getting
about one level per uh tree checked so
pretty quick still okay so I bought a
little bit more big bones uh this should
get me another couple levels and that
should be pretty close to 750 okay there
we go there's level 31 prayer and we can
now use the ultimate strength prayer
which will actually be kind of useful
once I start training at Moss Giants uh
another thing we have coming in is the
boots of Darkness flip this one was
insanely good and they actually all sold
at once all 10 of them in 1 second I'm
not sure why but uh we sold them for
1420 and bought them for 910 so that is
a 500K flip which is just so good for
the price okay we have another prayer
level coming in that should be 33 re
prayer I think uh yeah 33 perfect and I
think that's also going to be level 750
total that is awesome now I have fully
unlocked the um sewer system so I can go
ahead and finally actually train my
combat or range much more effectively so
I can finally train on something that's
not guards this is really exciting uh
there's a whole host of monsters down
here but I'm at the combat level where
Moss Giants are going to be the best
ones already uh before I was getting
like 15K XP an hour and I'm getting up
to 25k if I'm paying attention uh so
pretty noticeable difference plus these
guys actually drop valuable things
occasionally like there's a herb I mean
they drop RAR seeds pretty frequently uh
which are worth about 30k each overall
just better and just more uh
entertaining for me I don't know how
I've gotten so many of these maze
randoms I almost never get them on my
main account and I've probably gotten
like six or seven of these so far when
really all I want is the XP lamp one
uh that being said that was actually a
pretty good reward I can't complain too
much about that it's like uh 35k okay
we're just about to hit a strength level
there is level 43 strength uh getting up
there slowly and I think our Max hit may
have increased by one pretty recently
which is nice I can now hit an 11 all
right there is level 35 strength only
took a half an hour to level up for the
last two levels that's nice H now I'm
just going to go work on my attack and I
think maybe I'll get my defense up but
it's not a huge deal cuz it's not like
anything here can do much damage anyway
even these Moss Giants really aren't
hitting me that much all right and we're
just about to hit Level 45 attack now uh
that's where I'm going to stop for now
but I don't really know if there's
another weapon I can use besides the run
simitar I know the brine saver is a
little bit better but is there anything
substantially better I can use before
like an Abyssal Whip or something like
that uh because I really would like to
switch off the run citar because it's
just free to play there has to be
something better than that in pay to
play okay there's level 63 wood cutting
I'm just kind of slowly picking away at
this I don't really see a point of
having a high wood cutting level except
for increasing my total level of course
and honestly I was just doing this uh so
I could turn them into uncut long bows
and then string them kind of like an
Iron Man uh but yeah there we go another
wooden level and we're going to put 80k
GP an hour from UL logs which is pretty
bad okay so have another nine of these
boots of Darkness coming through they
are probably the best item of flip so
far uh we didn't sell them 152 but
that's not a huge deal a huge margin has
room to work with here I'll put them in
for 139 that'll still be probably 800 to
900k in profit off that single item okay
so I calculated it out I need about
1,800 Oak planks to go from 44
construction to 55 uh now I did kind of
mess around trying to figure out the pts
which can give you like a plus one to
three boost but I just didn't see the
point it was really weird the way you
did it too uh but anyway I'll just go to
55 I don't really care too much okay so
I'm just going to continue to make the
oak larders CU as far as I'm aware this
is the best way to level up your
construction at this level uh but
there's 45 construction uh this should
honestly only take an hour it's a little
click intensive but pretty quick
experience even without a butler okay we
got another Construction level coming in
that should be level 50 construction and
I'm getting pretty well about 120k
construction experience per hour that's
not great as far as construction
experience goes but you have to remember
I don't have a butler and I'm
teleporting back to the gr exchange
every time so it's not the most
efficient way to train your construction
all right there we go we're just about
to hit another Fletching level that
should be level 78 Fletching again just
kind of slowly picking away at this this
does have a benefit to be higher level
so I'm definitely going to probably Max
this one out first I'd say this would
probably be uh my first and maybe only
99 if I were to get one uh cuz it's very
AFK profitable and pretty quick
experience and uh also looks like I had
about 800k worth of you long bows in the
bank I totally forgot about there we go
that's always nice okay so we're back on
the construction grind I think this
should be the last inventory I need one
more Oak Larder there we go there is 55
construction I can now build a formal
garden and an armor stand which is the
most important part about this so we'll
go ahead and make the stand okay so we
got the Limestone brick and the oak
planks there we go there is the armor
stand so I'm assuming I just bring
broken armor and use it on it uh and
yeah it's a little bit cheaper than
using the NPC but more importantly it's
just available at all to me because I
can't use the NPC on my challenge all
right so the M Giants aren't only good
for training melees they're actually
pretty good for range because their
defense is literally zero uh they have
zero defense in anything so they're
pretty much weak to everything uh and
there's also this really nice safe spot
in the corner which is very helpful
because having to run back here for food
does take a while uh but there we go
there's level 47 range I'm looking
forward to getting to 50 because I can
finally upgrade to something that's not
snakes skin armor okay so we have a
couple of our items selling but I'm
probably going to have to redo the
offers here and uh we did do a guthan's
Helm uh item overnight so we bought it
uh the empty version as in that's one
that's been fully used up and I'm going
to go test using on the armor repair
stand in my house now the cost of all
the barrels items are dropping
significantly so I might not make money
on this but I did want to give it a try
okay so I think I just use it on the
armor stand and there we go so 49k as
opposed to I think it's 60k at at the
NPC so it's definitely cheaper uh that
being said I don't think I made any
money on this but uh I think in the
future this will be very useful okay and
we have another Willow Tree grown that
is going to be level 35 farming and uh
and considering buying my way to 42 so I
can plant maple trees just to speed
things up I both have to see what our
cash tack is looking like all right guys
uh my freaking recorder crashed again
I'm so mad I don't know what happened I
recorded all then it just corrupted
after anyway I did end up selling off um
all the darkness items uh for just a bit
cheaper as well as a GTH chain skirt
here we flipped 501 into 593 minus the
cost to repair it's only about 30k so
it's not that great uh because all the
barrows items are crashing right now
it's going to I'm going have to wait for
it to stabilize a little bit before this
method it's going to be useful but I am
glad I got my construction to 55 now um
just because this clip got trashed in
the last one too it's making the
challenging to finish this I think I'm
just going to release it it's only going
to be 10 or 11 minutes I hope you guys
understand but it's really frustrating
when um you have to do stuff again and
I'm kind of sick at the same time I've
already talked so much today I can't
bear to try to record that again so I'm
just going to end it for today guys so
while this is going to be a pretty short
episode I did make a good amount of
progress I got to my goal of 750 total
plus an extra 33 levels those are mainly
coming from combat we got uh 10 combat
levels uh a couple range levels prayer
we got up six levels and uh construction
also is a huge one really happy I got my
Construction level up it was probably
about 1.5 mil to get it from 0 to 55 so
it's really not too expensive definitely
going to be worth it although I can't
really use the portal room uh it still
would be useful for you guys just so
you're aware um beyond that I also got
my farming a little bit up to about 50
or 35 sorry as well as some wood cutting
levels and one Fletching level now for
my cash dech that is looking a little
more promising I have 624k in my
inventory right now but I also am
investing in some Monk robes G the price
has dropped like everything else but
this one a little more dramatically and
I think I might be able to snipe it for
this price but either way you can see
him with about 4.5 mil in money so that
is going well well definitely going to
make a push to try to get a growing cash
tag it is going slowly but it'll be nice
to jump start it with a method or
something anyway guys I hope you enjoyed
and I will see you guys in episode
number 11
[Music]